[Music]
including the righteous gemstones and
the shield his acting career spans
around 30 years overall now Goggins is
starring in a new CBS sitcom called the
unicorn he plays Wade he's a father and
widower who is getting back into dating
with a little help from his friends you
are a unicorn I'm away are unicorn you
know that elusive creature they're all
single women are looking for see most of
the men on these dating sites are having
midlife crisis they're getting divorced
they're buying Porsches yeah they're
hooking up with 25 year olds you are a
devoted father you are devoted husband
and not for nothing we haven't had sex
with anybody besides Jill in like 20
years
so you're factory-fresh buddy
technically he's like certified preowned
why you got to put your own spin on
everything good morning what a man
indeed I have to say that the premise
for this show would not immediately
strike one as fodder for comedy the
guy's life passes away yeah he's nothing
in the aftermath of that yeah yeah
that's right yeah but but you say this
is kind of the life on the other side of
trash you know I mean yeah his wife
passed away and he has he has two
daughters and and yeah like like at
first glance that wouldn't be funny but
pain and joy are infused with absurdity
and and that's that's what life is life
is funny in those moments and and this
is a story about his community kind of
coming together to help him learn how to
how to live again yeah the dating the
dating world has changed a lot since
Wade was left in it yeah yeah does he
adapt to that yeah well I mean it's like
being dropped off on Mars to be quite
honest and it's a show about dating but
really it's about much more than days
yeah it is about yeah it's about it's
about learning how to live again
yeah it's about community and it's about
kindness and and it's earnest and it's
and it's from the heart and it's absurd
and the comedy is kind of borne out of
all of these situations you know I think
I think for us as people the thing that
unifies us all is struggle we all go
through
times in our life whether you're you
know you you get a divorce or you've
lost a job or you have an aging parent
they're all new normals and we all have
to learn to adapt to these new
situations but how did you figure out
how to get me and then what did you
learn about online dating that you
didn't know before having to make this
leap through your character Oh weren't
you at the table aren't you glad you're
out there dating yeah well you know I
don't know the biggest takeaway from me
was just how exhausting it is just
filling out a profile would I would have
to take a nap yeah yeah I don't know I I
was talking to someone about it last
night and then I said what are you what
do you what are you looking for like
what do you what do you really really
want like is it is it commitment like
what what is it and they said you know I
don't know that we've really figured
that out yet you know for this
generation and like what they're kind of
getting from from dating kind of online
I want a sense of humor right
intelligent were you asking me yeah this
is the thing about you Walton that I
think is so interesting because you play
such a variety of roles I know it's
called acting yeah but you also at the
same time while you're shooting this you
were shooting a role for HBO yeah yeah
which is taken off and is huge yeah yeah
you were able to do you know I it's the
the the the opportunities that I've been
given over the course of my career I
have a more often than not been able to
kind of hide behind something you know
and and the righteous gemstones I'm
playing a 70 year old man but but the
Unicorn is is me that's the relationship
that I have with my son with my with my
wife and with our with our group of
friends what what these people go
through and this show is what I go
through kind of getting out of the house
like every single morning but you left
the south and came here with 300 came to
California with $300 in your pocket what
yeah that's exactly right yeah you know
I only ever wanted to see the world like
that was the most important thing for me
and while I did come to Los Angeles in a
way to become an actor it was really
about understanding people and listening
to stories and I've always loved hearing
people's stories
and and and it worked out for me you
know does the southern accent ever slip
out again oh yeah it comes out right now
[Laughter]
Congrats Congrats one Baker very much
very funny